[Musique]
mon invité ce matin Guilhem Giraud
bonjour bonjour vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre confidence d'un agent du
renseignement français aux éditions
Robert Laffont merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce livre en
gros c'est le récit de votre parcours
d'abord au sein de la DST ce qui
s'appelait désormais la direction ça
s'appelait la direction de la
surveillance du territoire c'est devenu
la destéries depuis Nicolas Sarkozy vous
y avez été formé dans votre service
militaire vous avez fait une partie de
votre carrière avant d'aller au
ministère de la Justice ensuite dans la
sécurité privée en tant que spécialiste
des écoutes des renseignements en gros
vous êtes ingénieur de formation
spécialisé dans le contres espionnage et
vous le précisez bien dans le livre vous
n'êtes pas un espion absolument mais
vous utilisez des logiciels espions en
quoi consiste votre travail mon travail
consiste à apporter aux espions entre
guillemets mais aussi à d'autres forces
de sécurité les moyens de réaliser leurs
opérations sur les technologies donc je
suis ingénieur Télécom de formation et
je mets en oeuvre toutes les techniques
qui permettent d'accéder aux
présentation des cibles du renseignement
et de la justice quand je le disais on
va voir on voit votre parcours dans ce
livre et puis il y a un grand fait
marquant dans ce livre ce qui est à
l'origine de tout cela c'est un déclic
il y a quelques années vous êtes
installé dans un pays du Golfe ou vous
conseiller une pétromonarchie en matière
de renseignement
vous suivez vous vous marchez dans les
clous en tout cas selon votre code à
vous et puis un jour un jour on vous
fait une demande particulière
racontez-moi absolument alors c'était en
2016 et comme vous le dites mon secteur
d'activité est très codé normé j'ai
travaillé pendant 25 ans dans ce secteur
on ne sort jamais de la procédure parce
que c'est un c'est un garde-fou contre
tentative de récupération de ces outils
donc quand je quand je réalise un
dispositif je suis saisi officiellement
je suis une procédure et à tout moment
si vous voulez de mon travail il y a des
points de contrôle entre guillemets
c'est à dire que par exemple en France
vous imaginez bien que personne ne peut
réaliser des écoutes sans que l'État
l'état profond et au fonctionnaires soit
au courant et sans que des moyens qui
sont annexés au Parlement des
commissions parlementaires soit en
mesure à n'importe quel moment de
contrôler tout ce qui se passe donc en
2016 je suis dans mon bureau entre
guillemets je fais ce que j'ai à faire
et une base militaire dans un pays du
Golfe sans fenêtre exactement leur
informatique et d'habitude vous voyez
que des militaires je vois que des
militaires et je suis tout seul dans mon
bureau en fait on m'a donné entre
guillemets carte blanche pour réaliser
un centre de données et protéger des
communications sensibles pour les plus
hautes autorités de l'État et ce jour-là
m'attend à la porte de mon bureau donc
c'est en 2016 elle était 2016 maintenant
à la porte de mon bureau un conseiller
très proche du chef de l'État qui
s'adresse directement à moi ce qui déjà
n'est absolument pas lieu au canal
officiel pour me saisir et de but en
blanc il me tend un post-it avec un
numéro de téléphone gryphoné dessus il
me dit il faut que tu appelles ce numéro
c'est un nouveau logiciel tout le monde
le veut ici dans la région avec ça on
peut écouter tout le monde
compris nos amis y compris nos amis donc
quand je le questionne un peu sur que
veut dire ce tout le monde il dit aussi
des gens peut-être peut-être ce sont nos
amis mais on en est pas sûr donc là on
est typiquement si vous voulez pour moi
dans mon métier on est typiquement dans
dans la dans la récupération d'un outil
à des fins personnels entre guillemets
donc les les autorités de l'État sont un
rôle institutionnel mais reste des
personnes restent des êtres humains ils
ont des intérêts humains et là si vous
voulez quand on me demande ça je
comprends immédiatement que c'est pour
détourner un outil
à vocation souveraine nationale à des
fins à des fins quasi personnels donc
j'appelle le numéro
je raconte donc ça dans dans le livre
dans le premier chapitre la personne que
j'ai au téléphone c'est un des
fondateurs de la société NSO donc qui
édite le logiciel Pegasus
et je lui dis qu'on m'a demandé de lui
téléphoner il me dit si vous voulez en
savoir plus il faut venir en Israël
parceo est une société voilà ce que je
décline parce que je suis donc passé par
la DST dans mes jeunes années et on m'a
dit ne va pas en Israël ne va pas en
Chine voilà bon donc je ne vais pas en
Israël je suis jamais allé je pense que
je n'irai jamais parce que pour moi
c'est trop c'est trop dangereux pour mon
métier
et donc je décline et la conversation
s'arrête là
je rends un rapport donc à l'autorité
qui a qui a diligé cette personne et je
lui dis de toute façon
ne vous lancez pas dans ce genre de
logiciel je me suis renseigné sont des
gens qui qui font qui font ça de manière
beaucoup trop libérale vous prenez des
risques extrêmement importants en termes
d'image et de crédibilité pour vous-même
et pour pour votre pays bon j'avais pas
tellement tort puisque quelques années
plus tard donc l'enquête les enquêtes il
y a eu des enquêtes journalistiques mais
il y a aussi une commission de l'Union
européenne qui qui est en train de
d'étudier sérieusement la question ont
montré que ce logiciel a été
complètement dévoyé et utilisé sur des
journalistes des opposants
des catégories de personnes qui
devraient être et qui sont protégés dans
les populations dans les pays dans les
pays démocratiques ça Pegasus c'est donc
créé par ce groupe israélien NSO il y a
notamment le consortium des journalistes
forbidden stories qui va révéler toute
une série de de fuite lancée par un
lanceur d'alerte on apprend qu'un pays
espionne le Premier ministre français
Édouard Philippe peut-être un pays du
Maghreb n'en saura pas vraiment que ce
logiciel est utilisé par l'Espagne pour
espionner les indépendantistes catalans
par la Belgique par le Mexique par le
Togo la Grèce l'Arabie Saoudite tout ça
pour espionner par exemple des opposants
des journalistes c'est quoi le danger de
pégaseus le danger de Pegasus c'est
premièrement on nous enseigne quand on
travaille un peu dans ces milieux là que
un outil de renseignement qui n'est pas
bien calibré pour s'insérer dans un
dispositif n'est pas efficace donc en
fait vous pensez faire un bon coup et
vous vous tirez une belle dans le pied
c'est comme avec ça on peut tout faire
on peut tout faire au téléphone portable
à peu près n'importe comment
exactement en fait le à l'origine de
Pegasus si un phénomène beaucoup plus
profond et beaucoup plus alarmant
Pegasus c'est un peu l'arbre qui cache
la forêt ça n'est qu'une conséquence
d'un phénom beaucoup plus large c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il est possible et il est
même judicieux de réaliser des écoutes
directement sur le téléphone en y
injectant un logiciel espion ça c'est
nouveau auparavant jusqu'à une dizaine
d'années à peu près la manière de
réaliser des écoutes c'était via un
opérateur téléphonique d'un pays et là
forcément si vous voulez ça laisse des
traces c'est très bien contrôlé avec ce
nouveau procédé qui est non seulement
plus intéressant parce que avec tout le
chiffrement des communications
aujourd'hui c'est mieux d'accéder à la
source de la communication pour la
capter directement à l'origine avant
qu'elle ne soit chiffrée dans le réseau
et ça devient non seulement possible
mais judicieux de se passer en quelque
sorte de tout de tout ce dispositif
d'État qui vient contrôler la procédure
donc en fait vous avez des sociétés qui
aujourd'hui sont capables théoriquement
de se mettre au service de n'importe qui
et quand je dis n'importe qui ça peut
être aussi bien un milliardaire qui a
envie de faire des écoutes pour son
propre compte
un article est paru récemment il y a une
dizaine de jours les journalistes se
questionnent sérieusement sur le fait
qu'au Mexique des cartels ait eu accès
aussi à ce logiciel parce que les gens
qui ont été ciblés étaient des opposants
en notoire au cartel donc c'est c'est
vraiment très très inquiétant parce que
c'est c'est un mode de fonctionnement
nouveau qui met en cause nos démocraties
si on n'y prend pas garde écouter tout
le monde c'est extrêmement dangereux et
c'est vicieux parce que alors c'est
peut-être pas forcément le cas de
Pegasus mais pour d'autres logiciels
est-ce qu'on appelle des backdoor c'est
à dire que la compagnie qui fait ce
logiciel peut avoir accès aux données
intercepter pourquoi pas les vendre
encore un solitaire et ainsi de suite il
y a eu plusieurs scandales les bacs d'or
existent depuis plus longtemps que ces
logiciels parce que les backdov ont pu
être installés par des fournisseurs
d'État dans les réseaux téléphoniques
donc une bague d'or effectivement vous
pouvez en avoir une sur votre téléphone
quand vous êtes espionné mais il y a eu
il y a eu des scandales de backdoor
célèbres on va dire par exemple en Grèce
il y a eu plusieurs scandales avec des
opérateurs ce qu'on appelle des
équipements entiers Telecom qui avait
installé des backdoor dans le livre
aussi je raconte un épisode où je voyage
dans un pays européen et je découvre les
officiers sur place me font part d'une
de mes aventures qu'ils ont eu aussi
avec un équipementier israélien qui
avait placé une bague d'or sur leur
système c'est les Néerlandais
il y a pas de plus la France aussi enfin
il y a des sociétés françaises qui qui
font ce type de logiciel c'est pas tout
à fait exactement les mêmes et
d'ailleurs vous allez travailler pour
l'un d'eux amesis il y a cosmos aussi
amésis ça servi au régime de moi
marcadhafi pour espionner ses opposants
pour le cas de cosmos ça a été utilisé
par le régime de Bachar al-Assad dans le
livre on apprend que vous avez formé
d'ailleurs des Libyens quel était votre
rôle mon rôle en quelque sorte c'était
d'apporter de la ressource humaine parce
que quand j'étais embauché par unes ils
étaient désespérément en quête de
personnes qualifiées pour exécuter un
contrat qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
contracté avec le régime libyen donc je
suis tombé un peu en quelque sorte au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment ce que
j'avais négocié avec la direction
générale d'amnésie c'était de les aider
à s'engager sur le chemin des
interceptions légales parce que ils
avaient ils avaient construit un système
qui ne s'insérait pas dans le dispositif
légal européen ce que j'ai réussi à
faire puisque on a ensuite l'année
suivante donc vendu un tel système
cependant quand je suis entrer dans la
société ils avaient désespérant mon
besoin de de personnes à montrer à leurs
clients et j'y suis allé et par en
quelque sorte contre j'étais en période
d'essai et contraint je j'ai dû former
des des opérateurs bon j'ai pas été bon
du tout et je pense que c'est la seule
fois dans ma carrière où je peux me
vanter de ne pas avoir été bon c'était
plutôt positif pour moi vous avez quitté
cette société qu'est-ce qu'on sait les
systèmes de surveillance qui existe
aujourd'hui côté de la Chine et de la
Russie alors on ne sait pas grand chose
sauf que dans le dans le milieu on dit
que ce sont des systèmes qui sont
dimensionnés pour écouter tout le monde
par par construction en quelque sorte
quand un opérateur européen operateur
Télécom européen délivre un réseau la
fonction d'interception elle vient après
le système n'est pas conçu pour
intercepter d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'il y a des équipes dans l'état
profond entre guillemets dont je faisais
partie qui était là pour plancher sur
les manières de récupérer les
informations là où ils étaient je peux
vous dire qu'on embêtait
personnel des opérateurs et c'était un
projet qui était suivi par Bercy les
opérateurs étaient dédommagés des
actions qui mettaient en oeuvre pour
mettre en place les écoutes en Chine et
en Russie ce que l'on dit j'y suis
jamais allé c'est open c'est à dire
c'est par construction vous avez pas
besoin d'un service comme comme celui
que je vous décris pour aller faire les
écoutes ce qu'on nous a toujours dit
j'ai pas pu le vérifier mais ce qu'on
nous a toujours dit c'est qu'en gros
vous appuyez sur un bouton et l'écoute
et déversée dans dans le silo qui va
bien
mais voilà qui est attitant merci
beaucoup Guilhem Giraud je suis désolé
on est pressé par le temps parce que
c'est évident un agent du renseignement
français donc aux éditions Lafont et ça
vient de sortir merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin merci à vous
d'avoir choisi France 24 on se retrouve
dans 4 minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]